[Applause]
when you were a little kid I wanted to
be alive and great circumstances I grew
up in the hood I was surrounded by you
know a lot of violence like crime yeah I
was a definitely a product of my
environment yeah I kind of snapped out
of it when I was older when I realized
it was kind of a dead world my mom
helped me you know she she sent me to
live with my dad when I was I think
about 12 13 when I was bigger than her
and getting in tons of trouble yeah so I
really didn't know I didn't honestly
know what I wanted to do with my life
like for the rest of my life I was about
30 years old and that's when I knew that
I wanted to be I wanted to entertain
people that's so cool and so cool to say
and own because a lot of people give up
on their dreams because they think
they've aged out of whatever bracket
Society tells you you're supposed to be
in and that's cool I get 30 you were
like I want to do this yeah I really my
life started at 30 yeah if I wasted my
20s I bounced in my clubs from the time
I was 17 till I was 30 Wow yeah that's
what I did
right on and you're all good she'd like
wish she looked any better she that's
probably like wait what your childhood
well even what I wanted to professional
wrestling because I was such an
introverted kid she just like that's you
speaking in front of thousands of people
I can't believe it but my mom is
actually my my biggest fan like by far
that's so cool subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going